we talk a lot about the Trump
indictments but president Trump is not
the only conservative that our liberal
ruling class is trying to put behind
bars in fact today this week and today
specifically liberals in Georgia are
rounding up 18 co-defendants in the
Trump case
who are they well one is Mark Meadows
former U.S congressman former white
house chief of staff
he's being arrested for being on a phone
call with the Georgia Secretary of State
and the president of the United States
in which the president raised the
prospect of election fraud
another one is my friend Jenna Ellis who
is being arrested for committing the
crime of being the president's lawyer
another one is John Eastman another
lawyer extremely respected great guy
indicted for believing that there might
have been some questions about the
propriety of the election and Advising
his client on how best to navigate that
whole bunch of other lawyers including
Rudy Giuliani greatest mayor in the
history of New York City indicted for
basically the same thing
Jeffrey Clark a former doj official Who
quote identified significant concerns
about the 2020 election those concerns
are apparently enough to get you
arrested in Joe Biden's America David
Shaffer
former head of the Georgia Republican
party being prosecuted for objecting to
the way that the election was conducted
Stephen Lee a pastor
a pastor who is being prosecuted for
knocking on the door of an election
worker knocking on the door
and on and on
to say nothing of the midwestern
grannies who were locked up the hapless
protesters thrown in solitary
confinement for months and months for
walking around the capital rotunda on
January 6th the worst day
three of those whole world
incarcerated just months after BLM
arsonists looters and rioters walked
free with Nary a slap on the wrist
these people
mostly lawyers and political activists
are not being incarcerated for any
particular crimes
plenty of people have committed the same
or more egregious versions much more
egregious versions of these supposed
transgressions and never received a
knock on the door from the authorities
these people are being prosecuted
for their politics for which side
they're on which party they belong to
which candidates they help they are
effectively political prisoners and with
no sign of the prosecution slowing down
one now has to ask a very sad question
by the end of 2024 which country will
have more per capita political prisoners
communist China
Putin's Russia or the good old us of a
I'm Michael knowlesis the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show speaking of our
rulers Joe Biden just touched down in
Maui and decided to make the national
catastrophe where likely a thousand
people at least have been killed lots of
children he decided to make that all
about a kitchen fire in his house so
we'll get to that in one second first
though did you ever think
you would ask that question about your
own country
how many more political prisoners are we
going to get
who's going to have more political
prisoners us or some awful terrible
countries no good rotten regimes around
the world I I guess I was just a little
naive I didn't think we did that in the
United States
I wasn't so naive
that that I didn't realize that people
in power sometimes pursue political
advantage and punish political enemies I
knew that
I just never thought we would get to the
point where
we would be arresting lawyers for
representing for having the gall the
temerity to represent the president of
the United States where we would be
actually arresting
candidates former presidents leaders of
the opposition like Trump of course and
pretty much anyone Trump's ever met
for having the gumption to question an
election that was obviously rigged
regardless of what you think about well
would Trump have won or did Biden really
get a bazillion votes or whatever we
know they changed all the rules in the
months and weeks before the election we
know they did this to the advantage of
Democrats we know they did this in a way
in which even Democrats previously had
admitted it that it opens the system up
to fraud
we know that they did it in violation of
the state constitution in the case of
Pennsylvania we all know that and so
then Trump's lawyers and some activists
and some Republican leaders and a pastor
I don't know Ordinary People raise a
question about that
I'm not even saying they speak truth to
power I'm saying they raise questions to
power and they get thrown in the can for
it
did you ever think we'd be there I
didn't because the Democrats did all of
that in 2000 which with far less
justification than the Republicans did
in 2020 and we were told that was
patriotic dissent is patriotic remember
that Hillary continues to do it from
2016. Stacy Abrams continues to do it
from 2018 none of them are in prison
they're all feted they all go on CNN
they're all lauded as wonderful voices
of the people
but at any time any Republican does it
from from Donald Trump all the way down
to the midwestern granny they they get
thrown in the cell and and they they
throw away the key at least for a long
period of time now speaking
being harassed for questioning the
government
the vague ramaswami is in hot water
here's the headline the headline is the
vague ramaswamy is a 911 truther
revak ramaswamy says 911 was an inside
job and the government totally did it
and I saw that headline I said well you
know
I've known for vague for some time now
that that doesn't seem
like his view I mean that's a little
suspect to me let me look a little
deeper then I realized it's it's
basically a fake hit job from the media
he went on CNN to discuss it here's the
line of questioning a report in the
Atlantic that you gave an interview to
you said quote I think it is legitimate
to say how many police how many federal
agents were on the planes that hit the
Twin Towers maybe the answer is zero it
probably is zero for all I know right I
have no reason to think it was anything
other than zero but if we're doing a
comprehensive assessment of what
happened on 9 11 we have a 911
Commission absolutely there should be an
answer the public knows the answer to
explain to me what you meant there
this is really it's funny I mean the
Atlantic is playing the same game as CNN
it's funny what I said is on January 6th
I do believe that there were many
federal agents in the field and we
deserve to know who they are on 9 11
what I've said is that the government
lied and this is incontrovertible
evidence Caitlyn the government lied
about Saudi Arabia's involvement there
was a Saudi spy named albayumi who they
lied and the government lied in the 911
Commission lied we know that because
Declassified reports in 2021
was indeed what's that yeah the report
that the president but your quote here
are you telling me that the quote 20
years later yeah but are you telling me
I'm doing this wrong here because it
says
do I live in North Korea I I guess this
is part of my political naivete because
when I was a kid I was taught that the
media the journalists they exist to
speak truth to power all those other
terrible regimes around the world Russia
China North Korea they all just have
state propaganda for their media but not
us in America
and then I I watch this and what does
this woman say Caitlin Collins she says
how dare you question the government
about anything are you you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist he says no wait hold
on I'm not a crazy conspiracy theorist I
didn't say anything crazy I'm just
pointing out we know for a fact now even
Joe Biden would admit this we know that
the government did lie about at least
the involvement of Saudi Arabia in in
the in the intelligence apparatus in
Saudi Arabia and so they suppressed that
so we're just asking some questions
about about
the government that isn't that what
we're supposed to do aren't we supposed
to be skeptical of power I'm not saying
that it was you know some like space
aliens or or I'm not saying it was you
know George Bush was hijacking an
airplane I'm not saying anything like
that I'm just saying the government lied
about Saudi Arabia's involvement so we
should continue to press them on on
important National matters okay we now
know that because they lied and what
does this woman do
she interrupts him she says we know they
lied because great glorious leader Joe
Biden Declassified to the documents he
our great wonderful glorious leader of
the son Joe Biden good good wonderful
man he did it and so now that is the
truth before he did that whatever the
government previously said was the truth
but now that the Sun King Kim eel Biden
has declared that Saudi Arabia was
somewhat involved now we can say that
now all hail the Glorious leader
wait what yeah that's my point you're
making my point lady
could have been he could have been
speaking Korean on there wouldn't have
looked any different now
when you want answers to your problems
you you shouldn't deal with our liberal
establishment when you want a quick
answer to a problem like hey you just
ran out of propane you got to check out
cinch right now go to cinch.com use code
Knowles picture the perfect Summer Night
the warm breeze on your face as you
Lounge in your favorite chair outside
the grill is sizzling with Juicy Burgers
and the aroma of the food is
irresistible
you're salivating the drool is dripping
down your chin now imagine what this
perfect summer night would look like if
you went to turn on the grill and your
propane tank we're empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule requires no
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling steaks
or lighting up the patio heaters on a
cold night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks with promo
code nolts Canada wles that's cinch.com
or download the Cinch app and use promo
code nulls kwles to get your first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks this is a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer for details my
second thought on the Vivek 911 thing I
don't know I haven't looked that deeply
into it I don't really care what he said
to the Atlantic or he said to CNN or he
seemed to explain himself fine there
but even I don't know he was I I did see
he was on
Alex Stein's show
a conservative comedian and Alex Stein
gets a little more into kind of edgy
theories type things
and he said what do you think about 911
I think the government has lied about
parts of it and so you know we should
continue to ask questions
Mitch again I don't know I just it was
on a conservative comedy show I think
doesn't really interest me that much I I
disagree with the fake on a whole number
of issues so that didn't I didn't bat an
eyelash there I'm more interested in his
views on I don't know Free Speech or
corporate power or all the rest but
anyway he said that and that's the line
that the Liberals are running with to
which I say man
he must have a pretty good candidacy if
that's the best they've got if the best
they've got is a possibly in Artful
articulation of some aspect of the
release of previously classified
documents about a national tragedy that
occurred over 20 years ago
this guy must have a pretty squeaky
clean candidacy no sex scandal
no Financial Scandal no political
corruption
I mean I'm just talking about the Biden
family right there that would take out
the entire Biden family right there if
if we had a fair media
but they don't have any of that on Vivek
so they've got to go to some line he
said on a conservative podcast give me a
break the best they've got is he doesn't
believe every single thing that the 911
Commission concluded
some of which have been contradicted by
by Declassified documents within the
last couple years
he's probably feeling pretty good
heading into this debate speaking of the
debate
another friend of mine unfortunately
looks like he's going to be kept out of
the debate that would be Larry Elder
Larry Elder conservative libertarian
radio host in California ran for
governor of California he's running for
president now
he got gets to the airport at LAX he
thinks that he's qualified for the
debate he gets a call from Ronald
McDaniel at the head of the RNC saying
that he didn't qualify here's why
as you can see I'm at LAX in route to
Milwaukee I was just informed by the RNC
that I'm not qualified for the debate
why even though I exceeded the 40 000
individual donations required even
though I signed the pledge to support
the eventual nominee I even though I
submitted three polls where I was at
least one percent I was informed that
one of the polls is not eligible it's
the Rasmussen poll even though it was
the most accurate call in predicting
that Donald Trump would win in 2016 they
say it is affiliated with Donald Trump
and therefore it is not eligible and I
said to Ronald McDaniel the chairwoman
of the RNC if not affiliated with me she
said any poll affiliate with any
candidate is not eligible and no one
told me that until just now so we're
filing an emergency injunction to get me
up there this is absolutely BS one of
the candidates by the way offered a 20
gift certificate for a one dollar
donation that apparently is okay okay so
what he's referring to there at the end
I think it was bergam you know
who had no name recognition no support
so he decided to just give away gift
certificates if you gave a small
donation to his campaign he'd give you a
gift card of greater value to somewhere
else because he just wanted 40 000
donors to be able to get onto the debate
stage so what what about Larry here
the rules are the rules I guess he
technically doesn't qualify they can
keep him off the stage if they want
nobody's asked my opinion but if it were
me if I were running the RNC
I'd let him on
maybe he doesn't match the letter of the
law here but I think the spirit of the
law he's he's there because it's not as
though he's using the Donald Trump
polling firm he's certainly not using
the Larry Elder polling firm
I didn't realize that Rasmussen had this
direct relationship with Donald Trump
but even so rasmussen's a very respected
poll that's been around for a very long
time so it doesn't seem like this is
some cynical work around some
opportunistic rap I think he's got he
qualifies according to three polls one
of which I guess has a relationship with
Trump but don't forget Trump is
effectively running as the incumbent so
this is again a reason why this election
this primary race is different from any
other primary race in our lifetimes
because you've got the first president
running for a non-consecutive second
term since 1888 and so yeah I guess one
of the big polling firms has a
relationship with Trump
in a normal ordinary primary year that
would not be the case now it is I say
let him on the stage who cares who's It
Really Gonna Hurt
it's going to really hurt DeSantis
DeSantis is already going to be duking
it out with Vivek and Christy all night
long I don't think putting Larry Elder
up there is going to do very much
Larry Elders got an interesting
perspective he's got a slightly
different perspective than the other
candidates on that stage and frankly
Larry Elder is extremely libertarian so
it's not even like I particularly agree
with the ways in which his perspective
differ from the other guys on the stage
but I think come on you're gonna have a
debate have a debate
[Music]
Trump is out he's not going to be
participating in some ways it's going to
make the debate more interesting in that
you're not going to have the big
King of the Hill Top of the Heap
chairman of the board sucking all the
air out of the room so you're gonna have
all these other guys sniping at each
other which will make it more
interesting if not uh more significant
for the race right now because Trump is
up 30 40 points so put him on the stage
come on why not let Larry up there Larry
is really the reason they don't want him
on the stage is because I suspect the
other candidates don't want to have to
deal with Larry Elder because Larry
Elder is really really good in debates
he's really good in confrontational
scenarios Larry was just on The
Breakfast Club and he was
he was effectively called an Uncle Tom
Larry Elder's been called an Uncle Tom
his whole life I think he didn't he do a
movie called Uncle Tom and so he's dealt
with this smear his whole life and he
was somewhat subtly called an Uncle Tom
by the host of The Breakfast Club and
Larry just let him have it have you ever
heard the term a wake-up call
no it is an incident where a person of
color forgets that they are of color and
are reminded rather brutally by an
unexpected Act of racism
well I'm acutely aware Charlemagne that
I'm a black person just as you are a
black person and when Joe Biden insulted
you by saying you ain't really black we
don't know whether or not you want to
vote for me or vote for Donald Trump uh
the team to see me that should have been
a wake-up call on your part how dare
this guy come in here and insult you a
black man and tell you you got to think
a certain kind of way I'm amazed that
you weren't mad about that
um it upset me it's like I'm not letting
you upset me you know I mean I don't
tend to get upset over things like well
what I did say well you just not talking
about a wake-up call and it seemed to me
that that should have been a wake-up
call on your part to have a white guy
come in here who also said by the way uh
about Mitt Romney
um uh because he didn't want to put more
regulations on Wall Street going to put
y'all back in Chains and Joe Biden had
lied for decades about the Civil Rights
record claiming that he desegregated
movie theaters and restaurants and
Wilmington Delaware when he didn't any
didn't do any of that he lied and said
that he tried to visit Nelson Mandela
during apartheid South Africa he did not
and he came in here and told you you
aren't even black unless you think a
certain kind of way it seems to me that
should have been a wake-up call for you
but it wasn't apparently
absolutely devastating so that's part of
the reason I want him on the debate
stage I'm really looking forward to the
debate tonight I know some people are
saying it's not fair that Trump's not
there Trump needs to show up they need
to rip Trump apart if Trump showed up it
would be the Donald Trump show which I
get a kick out of I find it entertaining
but
the rest of the guys on stage would have
just been trying to take pot shots at
trump it probably wouldn't have worked
very well he would have maintained his
lead we wouldn't have really gotten very
much out of it now at least we're going
to get to see the differences between
all of the second tier and third tier
and fourth tier candidates and see if
any movement happens and see if right
now Ron DeSantis is still number two
maybe he can improve his position maybe
some candidates drop out and people
coalesce around DeSantis or maybe one of
the other candidates comes up takes that
number two spot from him it's going to
be a much less predictable interesting
debate than that and it'll be even more
interesting if Larry Elder gets up there
now to the point Larry Elder's making
here is a really good exchange and and
Larry is good at pointing out the
hypocrisy of the racism industry but
I don't think this is going to work in
the general if if Larry somehow became
the nominee or were a running mate or
something like that I don't think this
line of would work in the general
because the black vote is overwhelmingly
solidly Democrat and we might say that's
wrong and that's stupid and they should
vote for republicans and I think all of
that but it's just a fact
the black vote has not budged in decades
and on top of that racism doesn't mean
anything anymore the the word racist
according to the Democrats just means
bad
the work you'll just be accused of
racism if you in any way contradict
their views on anything or if you are
white at all you'll be called racist and
to the to the right because the right
has recognized that the word doesn't
mean anything I think the the attack has
less uh Venom than it used to there's
less potency than it used to so you know
Larry can come out and say well
Democrats are the real racists I just
don't think it's going to budge
anybody's vote
the Democrats who could be scandalized
by that and wake up and go to the other
side that's I think already happened
and the Republicans are much less afraid
of being called racist now because we
know how disingenuous it is so hope he
makes it to the debate I think he would
do a great job out there
the main guy in the race
has just promised though that he will
not go to
any of the debates now the debates are
about hiring somebody to do the job of
president when you want to hire someone
you got to check out ZipRecruiter right
now go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles if
you're hiring you know that it's
incredibly difficult to attract top
talent with the current labor market
conditions it's even harder than ever
that is why you want to partner like sip
recruiter who gets it zip recruiter
knows how tough it is right now but
they've figured out solutions for the
problems that you're facing try them for
free at ziprecruiter.com Knowles Canada
wlas to reach more of the right people
ZipRecruiter posts your job to over 100
job sites zip recruiters smart
technology finds great matches for your
job and then lets you invite the most
qualified people to apply for your job
their pricing is really straightforward
you can stick to your budget with no
surprises team up with a hiring partner
like sip recruiter who understands what
you need four out of five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to this exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the absolute number one
smartest way
to hire let me ask you something have
you ever thought Princess Diana's death
seemed a little bit sus you know we're
talking about one of the presidential
candidates got
stuck in some conspiracy theories
according to the media well we've got a
whole conspiracy theory deck here
you know the truth about seed oils you
know how that causes sunburns I don't
some people say I'm just asking
questions
just like a few of the questions that we
answered in the recent conspiracy field
episode of yes or no in this episode I'm
joined by daily wires Firebrand
the lovely Candace Owens check out this
clip
men who don't work out are like women
who cry on Tick Tock after their pet
bunny dies it's disordered weak and hard
to look at
that's just funny
aside from the game itself the yes or no
conspiracy expansion pack is here
it's now available in my collection at
dailywire.com shop with over 110 new
cards tackling such topics as the moon
landing government cover-ups and the
Denver Airport you can find out even
more about your friends and family and
judge their stances on the most hotly
contested conspiracies in American life
because the original game
it's just not controversial enough if
you have not gotten the full yes or no
game now would be the time we're going
to sell out of both of these things as
we always do so if you want it I would
go get it right now I don't know the
next time we're going to get it in stock
we're going to try to keep these things
printing but sometimes it takes a little
while so go to dailywire.com shop get
yours in the all new yes or no
conspiracy expansion pack today
we knew Trump wasn't going to go to this
debate he's having a conversation with
Tucker instead we've got a daily wire
backstage tonight so we'll be doing a
whole pre-show about it and talking
about it but Trump has now come out and
said he's not going to attend any of the
debates he says new CBS poll just out
has me leading the field by legendary
numbers Trump 62 46 points above to
sanctimonious who's crashing like an
ailing bird like an ailing bird
that's Vivid that's a very Vivid image
ramaswami 7 Pence 5 Scott 3 Haley 2
sloppy Chris Christie two percent Ada
Hutchinson won why do you spell it Ada I
don't know like the Broadway play was it
wasn't that a Broadway show Ada he said
anyway
the public knows who I am and what a
successful presidency I had with energy
independence strong borders and Military
biggest ever attacks and regulation cuts
no inflation strongest economy in
history and much more I will therefore
all caps I will therefore not be doing
the debates
okay I would say
that this is Bluster that he won't
attend this debate nor should he there's
no strategic reason for him to do it but
if this debate hurts his poll numbers
if this debate helps especially DeSantis
or even Vivek or someone else to really
start to Rally the field around him if a
number of candidates drop out maybe
Trump will have to show up to the second
debate that's what I would have said and
I would say that this is all Bluster
except for one line here the one line
here that tells me he might be serious
and has good reason to make this point
is he says the public knows who I am
the point of the debates
is to introduce yourself to the public
to get the public to know you to
convince them that you're the man for
the job
Donald Trump uniquely in the field has
already done that everyone has known who
Donald Trump is since the 80s at least
this guy has been a staple of American
public life
for 40 years more than 40 years and he's
been the president which is why yet
again I have to point out it's not a
regular presidential primary
he is running effectively as an
incumbent so the main advantage that he
would get from the debates is he could
show people who he is he could craft the
image about himself and rather than
letting other people craft the image of
him for the public
there's nothing he can do everybody
knows who Donald Trump is everybody has
some opinion about Donald Trump not one
word he's going to say in these debates
is going to change people's opinion of
him not one
it's the first time I think maybe he
actually won't show up
to the rest of them and the first time I
think
maybe he's right not to
I'm not sure who's harsher on Trump the
Democrats or the never Trump Republicans
there's a guy this is so sad there's a
guy Michael ludig who is a long time
respected conservative judge at least
you'd say originalist judge
who
now spends all of his time on liberal
news shows attacking Donald Trump and he
believes
that the constitution disqualifies Trump
from even running for president he lost
that election fair and square in what
was we now know
perhaps the fairest election in American
history hold on put a pause there hold
on
if you come to me and you make an
argument you say Michael
look obviously there were some
Shenanigans in the election but here is
why the burst water pipes and the
week-long counting of the votes and the
changing of all the election rules and
the violating of the State Constitution
here's why all of the Democrat
Shenanigans actually didn't affect the
outcome of the election and you made
that argument to me I would at least be
open to the argument
but if you come to me
and and you deny all of those things and
you deny all the shenanigans and you
deny all the the election policy changes
that even Democrats 10 years ago
admitted open the system up to fraud and
you look me in the face and you tell me
that it's the fairest election in
American history
I just can't believe that that's
obviously not true that is the
equivalent of Judge looted walking up to
me unzipping his fly relieving himself
on my leg and telling me that it is
raining completely absurd he goes on
disqualification
provision of Section 3 of the 14th
Amendment and therefore the the
imposition of that qualification for the
presidency is stated in perhaps the
clearest language possible in the
Constitution
and it is unmistakably applicable to uh
to the former president and his role and
and activities on on January 6th so the
question is not whether uh the uh
Section 3 of the 14th amendment applies
to the former president it
unquestionably does
here's a little trick this is just a
little rule of thumb in politics when
you want to discern serious political
speech from BS political speech
pay attention to the adverbs
the more adverbs that a politician uses
the more frequently the politician uses
those adverbs the the more Grand the
adverbs the more likely that he is not
quite confident of his position it is
incontrovertibly true it is so
manifestly obviously true in the
clearest possible language that Trump's
not qualified to run he's disqualified
where do you get that from
oh it's in the section three of the 14th
Amendment it's not but just but let me
just it's the it's obviously clearly
most seriously the fairest election ever
and so obviously manifestly clearly true
that Trump can't run again
okay well let me just see that what is
it section three you said section three
of of the 14th Amendment
okay disqualification from holding
office no person should be a senator or
representative in Congress or elector of
president and vice president or hold any
office civil or military under the
United States or under the state who
having previously taken an oath as a
member of Congress or is an officer of
the United States or as a member of any
state legislature or as an executive or
judicial officer of any state to support
the Constitution of the United States
shall have engaged in Insurrection or
Rebellion against the same or given Aid
or Comfort to the enemies thereof but
Congress may buy a vote of two-thirds of
each house remove such a disability
what's kind of interesting about section
three is it doesn't mention the
president it mentions the an elector of
the president mentioned Senators House
Representatives different officers of
different states State legislatures
executive and judicial officers of
States doesn't actually mention the
president of the United States and
more importantly it says that they won't
do it if they've engaged in Insurrection
or Rebellion or given Aid or Comfort to
the enemies thereof
has Donald Trump been charged with
insurrection to any of the January 6th
grannies get charged with Insurrection
is Donald Trump been convicted of any
crime
has any crime even close to to this sort
of thing
not to my knowledge I haven't I haven't
seen that have you seen that no
end the notion
that
because CNN calls him an insurrectionist
therefore he is eluded goes on he says
and well the only question is is this a
self-enforcing rule
is the or do you have to be you know
convicted by one of those pesky courts
or something like that
uh yeah I know I don't think you get
convicted by MSNBC dude I think
grief man this guy is so sad what
happened to this guy because I don't
want to downplay he was a very important
figure in the conservative legal
movement which had some problems and is
now in a process of being changed a
little bit it was a little too
procedural probably it was not
substantive enough got some good
victories obviously we got the Dobbs
Victory that's pretty phenomenal but but
some have questioned the wisdom of the
conservative
legal movement notably Adrian vermeul
the Harvard law professor who is right
wing and some other people have as well
because
there was a tendency among the
conservative legal movement
to squish at various times to say look
all we care about is the original public
meaning of the Constitution and the
original public meaning of statutes and
if that original public meaning leads us
to the place where we're going to kill
800 000 babies a year well look that's
just what it says we can't possibly use
any other interpretive principle we
can't possibly refer to say the
background principles of the natural law
to to come to a conclusion we can't
possibly exercise our judgment no no
we're just we're just automatons we're
robots applying the original public
meaning which itself was a
transformation by the way because the
original originalism was original
meaning not original original intent not
original public meaning but in any case
it's very sad to see what happened to
this guy and so many other people like
him who just got Driven Crazy by Trump
and made an idol out of their principles
their supposed principles and and in so
doing undermined all of their principles
does anyone really believe that throwing
the leader of the opposition into prison
for for holding a rally
in for calling for peace and
and all the rest of it that that's
that's really in keeping with the
American Republican tradition that
that's really in keeping with the rule
of law no nobody thinks that
but this guy's just been driven crazy
and now he's saying hey yeah the liberal
regime needs to imprison its political
enemies yeah go get them why because I
don't know the 14th Amendment says it
somewhere or say an invisible link
somewhere
very sad same thing happened to Bill
Crystal
Bill Crystal maybe you love him maybe
you hate him Bill Crystal was a very
influential guy on the right Bill
Crystal was so influential that he could
launch extremely ill-fated Wars and vice
presidential careers for decades
and now what does he do he just takes
pot shots
on blogs that nobody reads he's he is a
Democrat is effectively a liberal
Democrat
judge Michael ludic went from being a
giant of the conservative legal movement
to being the Ed McMahon to every hack
host on MSNBC very very sad why did that
happen I've got two explanations for it
I've got two explanations for how Trump
in particular has managed to drive these
people crazy one the cynical explanation
is that it's just jealousy
that these guys used to have a lot of
influence and power these guys used to
have their vision of what the Republican
Party should be be the dominant vision
and Trump came in and he returned to the
GOP in many ways to an older kind of
conservatism that was a little more
skeptical of free trade it was a little
more skeptical of immigration there was
a little more skeptical of Outsourcing
there was a little more skeptical of of
globalization
that was a little more skeptical of
liberalism for that matter
and they didn't like that and they saw
their influence Wayne and they saw their
their political Vision being put in the
back seat as other kinds of conservatism
had been put in the backseat for 50
years and they took their ball and went
home
and they said well if I can't have power
here I'm going to go over to the
Democrat Party better to better to reign
in Hell than serve in heaven okay that's
the cynical reason the charitable
explanation is that this is a failure of
political imagination
that these guys had just been stuck in a
rut and they believed that the three or
four hack talking points from the back
of a napkin that the Republican
politicians had been saying to no effect
for 30 years that that was the be-all
and end-all of conservatism
that conservatism began when these
people entered public life and it could
never change it could never deepen it
could never develop it could never refer
back to perhaps even deeper sources of
political thought
and when that began to happen when the
fashionable albertarianism and
neo-conservatism of the 1990s and 2000s
began to give way to deeper
understandings of conservatism Edmund
Burke Aristotle the natural law unit the
just the American tradition from the
founding not as it was
revised in children's books but as it
actually was in the 18th and 19th
centuries
as that happened they couldn't take it
they couldn't imagine that there was
more to politics than just cutting taxes
and flooding the country with foreigners
and bombing the Middle East and when
they couldn't imagine that there was
more to Legal conservatism than using a
crystal ball to figure out what a
handful of legislators thought in 1789
and when when their views were
challenged rather than allowing iron to
sharpen iron they went over to the bad
guys not good so that's that's the a
real Hazard of a failure of imagination
and despite the lackluster economy
the daily wire is thriving
we do not suffer from a failure of
imagination over here that's I don't
want to toot our own horn but at least
at least on the imagination front I
think we uh we're we're on the right
track so not only all of that
we're hiring we are currently looking
for a graphic designer to join our
faster and creative Department as a
graphic designer
you will collaborate with copywriters
creative directors and other designers
under the guidance of the executive
creative director to craft show assets
and thumbnails for a variety of media
to excel in this role you'll need to be
proficient in
Adobe Creative Cloud you'll have to have
experience creating engaging web
graphics
key and attention to detail excellent
communication and collaboration skills
the position is based here in Nashville
USA if you're interested in joining our
team
head on over to dailywear.com careers
that's dailywire.com careers today my
favorite comment yesterday is from
Stephanie Crowe 7387 says I wish you
would do a redo of Christopher Walken's
dance scene in your new office that's a
great idea here's actually a little bit
of trivia you know I've confessed
that in my prior Wayward youth
of my teens and early 20s I was a
professional actor and I know listen
we've all done things we're not proud of
some people got addicted to heroin some
people participated in orgies
I was a professional actor okay these
are I know these are shameful things but
what can we say
we have it people do these things
but when I was an actor I had the same
acting teacher as Christopher Walken
even though Christopher Walken is much
older than me he's 80 years old I am not
80 years old but I had a teacher who at
the time was 92 years old and he was
Chris Watkins teacher but he didn't
teach me to dance as well as he
apparently taught Chris
speaking of failures of imagination I
told you yesterday
that uh
The Masks are coming back
the lockdowns the covid measures they're
coming back right on time two and a half
years after they went away they're
coming back because covid-19
was just before the 2020 presidential
election 19 19 referred to 2019 and
covet 23 right here before the 2024
election to justify an upending of all
the voting rules again
Morris Brown College
has inaugurated this Lionsgate in
Hollywood said we're bringing back the
masks and Morris Brown College
as far as the universities go
says we're going to bring back the masks
and here's what they said
they said the mask mandate
is a precautionary move for the next 14
days
it's being reported by WSB-TV
14 days
does that sound familiar
two weeks
they're they're actually saying at
Morris Brown College hey hey we're not
no no we're not bringing the mask the
mask's back oh hey man we're not
bringing the coveted we're just
it's just two weeks to slow the spread
oh shoot we can't say two weeks because
then if we say two weeks they'll maybe
they'll remember that we did this exact
same thing last time ah let's say 14
days yeah yeah they won't they won't put
two and two together
they're not even changing the script
they're just doing the exact thing they
did during the last election the exact
to a t even after we know the masks
don't work this has now been admitted by
relevant authorities we now know that
the social distancing was arbitrary I
heard that from the FDA we now know
that the vaccines didn't do what we were
told they would do they didn't stop
people from Catching cover they didn't
stop people from spreading covet we now
know that a lot of the statistics we
heard early on in coveted were bogus
based on fake models we know all of that
it was all bogus man
and they're doing it again
how offensive it's it's so much more
offensive than even the fact that there
are
trying to lock us all down again and
take away our ability to run our own
country
the most offensive part is they're not
even getting creative about it total
failure of imagination speaking of
scripts and going off scripts uh
President Biden landed in Maui
one of the first things he says he lands
there and he makes he makes a joke
about the heat you guys catch the boots
out here
it's hot ground man
an estimated 480 people have been killed
at the very lowest estimate and 850 are
missing and the death toll is almost
certainly well above a thousand huh
pretty hot ground
isn't that funny
better wear some boots
then he goes on he's giving a speech
wearing a Hawaiian leis giving us a
speech
[Music]
and he
he has the temerity to compare the fire
we were talking about September 11th
earlier in the show if a thousand people
died in Maui who knows how many it could
have been more by the way if a thousand
people died that's that's a third of 9
11.
that is a third of what is considered to
be the greatest tragedy in American
history
and what does Joe Biden do he Compares
it to a kitchen fire in his house
I don't want to
compare difficulties but we have a
little sense Jill and I
what it's like to lose a home
years ago now 15 years ago I was in
Washington do we Meet the Press
it was a sunny Sunday
and lightning struck at home
on a little Lake it's outside of our
home and I don't like a big pond
and hit a wire and came up underneath
our home
into the heating ducts the air
conditioning duct to make a long story
short
I almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat
put all kidding aside
I watched the firefighters
the way they responded
no there's no expression
I grew up right across the street from a
fire hall in Claymont Delaware
you couldn't script this If you hired
the best writers in Hollywood you
couldn't script
he walks up there and he says ha ha yeah
I don't want to compare tragedies or
whatever but uh you know one time I had
this small kitchen fire that was very
quickly contained but and I know you
guys lost like hundreds and hundreds of
children like whole families burned up
and yeah but I almost lost my Corvette
anyway
what is wrong with this man
I'll tell you exactly what's wrong with
it I know exactly what's wrong with him
this I want to be as charitable as I can
you know I don't just throw bombs
this is an occupational hazard of
politics and Joe Biden is all politics
he is not a living breathing human being
with flesh he is just the a visible form
of politics
he doesn't have any thoughts he doesn't
have any beliefs he doesn't have any
principles he just
does whatever he thinks the crowd will
need to get him elected he's been in
politics for
the the majority of his life he's been
in at the national level for over 50
years
and Joe Biden charitably we would call
this empathy
okay this is the the ability of
politicians to
feel compassion with their constituents
or at least to perform compassion this
is why when Hillary Clinton went out
years ago and started putting on this
fake southern accent I don't feel no way
he's tired I I made fun of her but I I
felt for her because I don't think she
did that consciously I think she just
that's what politicians do they just
naturally feel some resonance with the
people that they're with and they they
try to find some common ground so you
could charitably call that empathy
you can uncharitably call it vanity just
making everything about themselves but
here's a good rule for solemn public
speeches when you're talking about
what appears to be turning out to be the
one of the greatest tragedies in
American history
delete the first person pronoun the
first person's singular pronoun just
delete it I don't care you're giving a
wedding toast you're giving a eulogy
you're giving a political speech after a
tragedy delete it
delete it's not about you man the in
polybius's
good old ancient uncle polybius
in his take on the cycle of regimes the
different kinds of regimes that can
Decay into their their bad version you
know you have monarchy monarchy can be
perfectly fine they're wonderful
monarchies in the history of the world
but then the bad version is tyranny
you know you've got aristocracy
that's the good version literally means
rule by the good and then you've got the
bad version that's oligarchy where
you've got democracy which
people have had conflicting views on
over the history but the bad version of
democracy according to our founding
fathers would be mob rule well what's
the difference what separates those
things uh Thomas Hobbes the author of
Leviathan one of the people who
inaugurated modern political science uh
one of the probably the grandfather we
would say of liberalism the classical
kind and the modern kind at all of it he
would say that there's really no
difference between those things it's
just we say one regime is good and the
other one is kind of bad ours when we do
it it's good when other people do it
it's bad but there's really no
substantive difference but what polybius
would say is what the ancient Greeks
would say is that the good version is
when
the Monarch or the aristocracy or the
Democracy are legislating for the common
good and the bad version is when the
Tyrant or the oligarchy or the mob are
are ruling for self-interest
and when a when a ruler just talks about
I mean my I mean my all the freaking
time you know what kind of regime you're
living under
the rest of the show continues now it's
work Wednesday baby you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Knowles
Canada WLS check out did I misspell my
own name boy man it's been a long
weekend it's gonna be a longer night
because we've got this debate tonight
and the Trump interview with Tucker so
head on over to dailywire.com use code
knowlescano w-l-e-s
that's how you spell my name for two
months free on all annual plans we'll
see you here in the membrane segmentum
of that
[Music]